today on the matt walsh show a school
district in california is forcing its
employees to intend
so-called white privilege training i'll
tell you what this
insane training entails and also i'll
ask a pertinent question that people
rarely ask which is
when is a white employee finally going
to stand up and file a racial
discrimination lawsuit to stop this sort
of madness because that's the only thing
that's going to stop it also
five headlines including more sheriffs
saying that they will not
enforce unconstitutional lockdown orders
and warner brothers gives the death blow
to movie theaters is that something to
celebrate
i don't think so and in our daily
cancellation i will preemptively cancel
any future potential covet vaccine
mandates
and anybody who pushes for them all of
that and more coming up today
on the matt wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
so a report from christopher ruffo who's
a writer with the city journal
says that teachers in the san diego
unified school district are being
forced to attend white privilege
training now before we get into the
details on this training we should note
that it's it's no surprise coming from
the san diego unified school district in
particular as this is the same district
that made headlines not long ago you may
have heard
for changing its grading system in order
to quote combat racism
the district noticed that black hispanic
native american students were failing
more than white students
rather than trying to rectify that by
helping the failing students perform
better
they decided instead to completely
change the rules
on the basis that the kids must be
failing because of racism
uh i can tell you that i was not a very
good student myself growing up you know
i was known to bring home
d's and e's on my report card um if only
i'd known that i was a victim of racism
i could have given that as an excuse to
my dad i ran out of excuses at a certain
point
but something tells me he would have
been unmoved
by that excuse and that's because my dad
is not a credulous idiot
unlike the people running many of our
school systems today especially in
california so
in san diego now final grades are based
not on yearly averages and students are
not penalized if they
you know turn in assignments late or
don't show up to class at all
bad behavior also doesn't count against
them none of that counts
the school board members who came up
with this brilliant plan explain that
now
now grading will be based on mastery of
the material
of course grades have always been based
on mastery of the material at least in
theory and the whole point is that
a kid who's acting out in class not
showing up half the time handing his
assignments in late
failing most of his tests probably
hasn't mastered the material
hence the failing grade on the report
card but that's not how it's going to
work anymore in this anti-racist
school district needless to say as
always though the attempts to be
anti-racist are themselves extremely
racist
the obvious implication here what is
being said without saying it
is that the minority students can't be
expected to show up to class or behave
themselves
so we have to change the rules to give
them a shot it's the bigotry of low
expectations
rearing its ugly head again racism in
the name of combating racism
as always and that brings us to the
latest report uh christopher ruffo
writes quote
san diego unified school district is
forcing teachers to attend
white privilege training in which
teachers are told
quote you are racist and quote you are
upholding racist ideas structures and
policies
the training begins with a quote land
acknowledgement
in which the teachers are asked to
accept that they are colonizers
living on stolen native american land
the powerpoint slide says quote
we must acknowledge the hidden history
of violence against indigenous people
in an effort to move towards justice
now hold on a second acknowledge
hidden history when is this not
acknowledged and how is it hidden it is
drilled into our heads at
every opportunity that the white
settlers were murderous land thieves has
anyone not heard this by now
it's acknowledged in fact way too often
and with too much hyperbole and with no
sense of perspective
the history of the entire globe every
settled part of it is a wash
in the blood of conquest that was the
case in the case in the americas
before white people ever showed up this
land was being fought over
people were killed over it brutalized
tortured enslaved
for centuries and centuries before
anyone with white skin
ever set foot on these shores does that
excuse whatever sins any white man may
have committed no but it does mean
that our reckoning with history must
include more than just white men
or else it's not a reckoning with
history at all it is a targeted attempt
to scapegoat a particular race of people
it is racist in other words this is
racist
and also by the way uh just so you know
there is no such thing as
native american land they were not one
group they were not a monolith
they were not homogeneous the native
american tribes didn't consider that oh
well this is native american
land we're all together we're all in
this together that's not how they saw it
they were warring tribes who again
killed and enslaved and tortured one
another
with abandon for centuries
if land was stolen from anyone it was
stolen from whatever group
just stole it from the last group the
idea that we have to look over this
whole series of conquest and theft
and place all the blamed moral guilt on
the most recent people to steal whatever
piece of land is just absolutely
ludicrous
we have we have reckoned enough with all
of the horrible things allegedly done by
white people
now it's everyone else's turn you know
countless sins have been committed by
countless people throughout history
who's next in line for public repentance
we've got the white man covered by now
okay we get it
so can we move on from that and let's
talk about the other
other people who did bad stuff now back
to roofo's report he says uh
then they the teachers are told they
will experience guilt
anger apathy and close-mindedness
because of their white fragility
after watching clips of robin d'angelo
and ibrahim kendy
the trainers tell the teachers you are
racist you are upholding racist ideas
structures and policies
that they must commit to becoming
anti-racist in the classroom
they must submit to the new racial
orthodoxy the teachers are told
that they are part of an oppressive
white power structure
the trainers claim that quote white
people in america hold most of the power
and that white teachers have an ability
to thrive that is being preserved at
every level of power
finally teachers are told that they must
become anti-racist activists
they must quote confront and examine
their white privilege
acknowledge when they feel white
fragility
and teach others to see their privilege
they must then turn their schools
into activist organizations okay
now a few additional points here first
there is one way to end this i can think
of only one way
to put an end to this madness
some white employee somewhere needs to
step up
and file a racial discrimination lawsuit
that's the only way this
ends of course there's no guarantee the
case would be successful given that
far-left radicalism invades every part
of our society including the courts
especially the courts
but on the merits it would be a rock
solid case
here you have an employer singling out
employees
by race and subjecting them to degrading
and insulting treatment and requiring
that they accept and embrace this
treatment
because they deserve it the employer is
saying
you are white and therefore you must
accept
that you are racist privileged and
fragile
this is just so absurdly illegal and
indefensible
and in violation of every racial
equality law and regulation
that it hardly requires further
explanation really there's probably no
scenario where an employer can say
you are fill in the blank race and
therefore you must accept that you are
fill in the blank adjective or trait it
doesn't even matter what you fill in the
blanks with
just imagine what it would sound like if
this was being targeted towards black or
hispanic employees
or gay employees or women and the matter
becomes clear
second point i go back to the same old
drum i've been beating for years
get your kids out of the public school
system this stuff is getting worse not
better the leftist indoctrination is
getting
more radical not less we are now in
full-on cult territory what these
teachers are undergoing is
nothing less than cult brainwashing now
we hear about the kids being brainwashed
but we should also remember
the teachers are being brainwashed too
you know if you listen to people who've
been brainwashed by cults
and then managed to deprogram themselves
they'll tell you that an important part
of the indoctrination process
is breaking the new recruit down making
them resentful of themselves their fan
families those closest to them the cult
seeks to sever the recruits ties
making them vulnerable susceptible in
need of affirmation and connection
then it's easy to come in give that
affirmation and win their loyalty
and their submission more importantly
and that's what's going on here
the yet the left uses the same playbook
and if you send your children to public
school
they are going to be in the clutches of
these brainwashed
cultist drones until your kids
themselves become brainwashed
cultist drones so don't do that to them
give your kids a fighting chance keep
them out of the public school system
there are a million reasons to avoid
public schools like the plague
and this is just the latest one now
let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
before we get to our five headlines
today you know i'm not someone
who normally would come on here and
preach about diversity it's not it's not
normally my bag
as you may have noticed but one place
where diversity
is certainly uh important is in your
investments you need to diversify your
investments and that means buying gold
problem is that buying gold is really
expensive not everybody has the ability
to do that so here's something that you
could try with our new sponsors acre
gold
uh if the as the price of gold is
skyrocketing
the new way to buy it is through this
company called acre acre lets you
subscribe to gold bars for as little as
30 bucks a month
what you do is you pay each month and
once your gold stash
reaches the price of their gold bars
they discreetly ship acre gold to your
house
and so that you can be you know you can
own gold you can be an investor in gold
even if it feels like it's it's an out
of reach goal because you don't have the
the money for it well here's a way to do
it
acre keeps you updated on your gold
stash every month it ships
you the once you reach that price
threshold it's going to ship it to you
again that's in a really discreet way
and acre just recently also we should
mention introduce their new 100
per month subscription for their 5 gram
gold bar so you could choose what level
you want to be involved in but the idea
here is to
invest in something stable something
that gives you some certainty for the
future
but also to do it in a way that's
affordable for you so you're not you're
not you know you're not you're not
stretching yourself too thin i think
this is the best possible solution
so visit getacregold.com walsh that's
get
acre gold.com walsh and start investing
in physical gold today make sure you go
to that url also because acre is giving
away a gold bar if you want to qualify
for the giveaway
just tweet or post why you should be the
recipient of the free gold bar
mention at get underscore acre if you
want to get that
free gold bar again that's
getacregold.com walsh and thank you to
akergold
for supporting the show so from the
daily wire it says on thursday los
angeles county sheriff alex villanueva
reportedly asserted that he won't force
his deputies to enforce
a new statewide stay-at-home order
against businesses issued by
california governor gavin newsom bill
mulligan of kttv
tweeted that sheriff elena tells me he
found out
about the new state homeowners from
gavin newsom's press conference there
was no coordination with local law
enforcement beforehand
which he says is concerning when the
government the governor is expecting
enforcement of his orders
villanueva told kttv i want to stay away
from businesses that are trying to
comply they bent over backwards to
modify
their operations to conform to these
orders and then they have the rug yanked
out from under them
that's a disservice i don't want to make
them more miserable
mulligan added sheriff phil nueva says
he believes the lakers and dodger
celebrations and thanksgiving
played a part in our recent surges at
the civil unrest protest earlier in the
year contributed to an earlier surge
uh doesn't believe that restaurants etc
are to blame okay so this is
just the latest we've heard a number of
sheriffs in various states
including california come out and say
that they're just not going to enforce
these orders
um because they're wrong misguided
unconstitutional evil
and destroying people's lives and that
that's exactly what needs to happen
and you know i think that's a message
that a lot of i understand that the
position this puts police officers in
when they're expected to be the ones who
go in
and you know arrest a restaurant owner
uh for serving food you know
that's a difficult spot that you're put
in as a police officer
but there are times when moral courage
is required and this is one of those
times
and i think if you're a police officer
you also have to keep in mind
you that you know you know you've got
one one one side one half
of the political spectrum that hates
your guts
unfairly okay they they believe that
you're racist
serial killers on the prowl hunting down
black men to kill that's what they
believe that's what they've been told
that's what the media says
and they hate you for that then you've
got
you've got us you've got conservatives
who are standing up for you and saying
that's not true
back the blue all of that uh blue lives
matter
that's all coming from conservatives i
think if you're a police officer you
really risk
alienating your only defenders the only
people on your side
if you enforce rules and laws like this
so i'm glad that this sheriff has
chosen not to number two article in ign
that says warner brothers announced an
industry-shaking approach to
to distributing its films in 2021
revealing that it'll be making all 17 of
its theatrical
theatrically released titles uh that
year available concurrently for a one
month exclusive window
on hbo max that means us-based consumers
will be able to watch highly anticipated
blockbusters including
dune the matrix four the suicide squad
mortal kombat
hold on a second didn't suicide squad
already come out
okay i'm being told there's a new one so
they're making a new suicide squad and
just calling it suicide squad again it's
not even suicide
squad two but they're putting the in
front of it
so it was suicide squad before now it's
the suicide squad
i mean it's unimaginative enough when
you're doing these dumb franchises but
can you at least get a little creative
with the title can you give us something
some kind of innovation anyway so
the suicide squad will be released
mortal kombat
and a bunch of others i think there's a
king kong versus godzilla coming out
all of that's going to be available on
streaming and apparently
um if you're an hbo max subscriber as of
right now they're not going to raise the
prices so you'll get to see it for the
same price you pay
for your normal subscription a lot of
people celebrating this move
um i don't see it as something to
celebrate because it's this is the death
of movie theaters
basically we knew we were already
heading in this direction but this
accelerates what was already going to
happen and i don't see that as a good
thing
now i know the movie theater experience
and it's not like you know i i have kids
now and
and we have to get a babysitter and you
know pay exorbitant
sums for the babysitter and then you
gotta go and buy the tickets and
everything it's like really expensive so
we don't go out to movies that often but
it's still i still like the fact that
movie theaters existed
and it's still an experience and so
what's happening now
is that all of our communal experiences
as people in a society are being taken
away and it's all migrating to the
internet
and one by one what used to be an event
an experience
that you would you would do it with
other people out in public
it's all just something that you now do
on your couch staring at a computer
screen
yeah even leaving aside all the jobs
that are getting wiped out so maybe
that's the number one problem
but um a strong number two is this
that these communal societal experiences
are being taken away
and uh i'm you know i think that's a sad
thing i think they'll probably still be
movie theaters
but now we're only going to have the
high end ones where they charge you 30
bucks a ticket and they they have to
you know they like serve food and
they're gonna have to provide
other things aside from just the movie
which is going to increase the prices
but it's not going to be like it like it
used to be i mean even
even renting a movie right used to be a
communal experience
because you would go to blockbuster you
know um
and you would walk around the aisles for
hours
looking for a movie fighting with your
siblings then you pick a movie you bring
it home
um you have to rewind it first because
the last person didn't rewind it that
was
an experience that was replaced by
netflix and now and now this too
all right um we have a few clips from
joe biden
as incoherent as always here's the first
one this is
joe biden explaining how he injured his
foot because we never really got an
explanation he's been walking around in
the
in the boot he injured himself somehow
we were told it had something to do with
the dog
um no one told us exactly what happened
but joe biden yesterday explained what
happened
and i'm still just as confused as i was
before listen
i got out of the shower i got a dog and
anybody's been around my house knows
dropped a little pup dropped a ball in
front of me and for me to grab the ball
and i'm walking through this little
alleyway to get to the bedroom
and i grabbed the ball like this and he
ran
and i was joking running after him to
grab his tail
and what happened was that he slid on a
throw rug
and i tripped on on the rug he slid on
that's what happened
oh man not not not very exciting story
i mean it is kind of an exciting story
actually
also kind of confusing what so what
happened he came out of the shower
so so he's he's what is he is he nude
i mean maybe these are details we don't
need but he's the one putting the image
in our heads
he's coming out of the shower the dog is
there he decides to so he grabs the ball
to play with the dog and then he decides
to chase after the dog to pull its tail
is that a normal thing that
dog owners do he throws that in like
it's something anyone does oh you know i
was chasing the pulse tail
what you're a 78 year old man you're
you're chase
you're coming out of the shower in a in
a in a towel
chasing the dog down the hallway to pull
its tail the dementia is worse than we
thought
and then the dog slips on the rug and
then he trips over
and falls down uh i'm not sure if i
believe that this is actually what
happened it's such a weird story i feel
like there's some
i don't know what happened but i'm not
sure if this is really what would
actually happen but it is uh
uh okay i don't know what to make of it
exactly
but i guess the lesson here is don't
chase your dog to pull its tail
especially when you're just coming out
of the shower you got wet feet
also we got another uh another another
clip from joe biden
he you know you've heard of 15 days to
slow the spread
you know we heard about that 15 days
fifth so there's a conversion
this is kind of like a math problem 15
days to slow the spread
was really six months seven eight months
however long it's been now i've lost
count
well now joe biden is talking about when
he if he becomes present
if and when 100 days to wear the mask
if 15 days is six months
how long is 100 days i don't know but
here's joe biden explaining it
and i think my inclination uh jake is on
the first
day i'm inaugurated to say i'm going to
ask the public for 100 days
to mask just 100 days to mask
not forever 100 days and i think we'll
see a significant reduction
if we occur that that occurs with
vaccinations and masking
to drive down the numbers considerably
100 days
why 100 days why not 95 why not 102.
why not 300. why not a thousand
why not five i mean it's just a random
number being pulled out of the
pulled out of the sky i'm just at just
just give me 100 days that's all wear
the mat where the cloth on your face for
100 days
after 100 days you can take it off
magically
well we know why he's choosing 100 days
because it is an arbitrary number
and they think it sounds more palatable
if they can just put a number on it
but if we do the conversion like i said
this is a mat i already told you i was a
bad student so i can't do the math
conversions here but maybe somebody can
15 days equals six months so 100 days
equals what we're looking at years
and that's unironically probably the
case
as we've been talking about all along
there is no limiting principle that i
can see
with this mask thing everything that
we're told about masks
you know uh they're they're safe they're
healthy
uh it's no big deal to wear them you
know it's you're protecting your fellow
man
all of this logic applies
covet or not regardless of covid all of
this still applies
so if this is the reason like we've
we've never really been given
a covid specific reason to wear a mask
we've been given a lot of sort of
general reasons to wear masks
and whether those reasons are good or
bad point is
they would still apply even if covet
doesn't exist
all right our friend alexandria caser
cortez has earned some mockery again
this time for selling
socialist merchandise on her website
which is already
ironic in and of itself but the best
part is this
tax the rich sweatshirt for uh 58
58 bucks for attacks the rich sweatshirt
um
and i guess we really shouldn't call
this ironic because socialists being
hypocritical
socialists trying to profit off of
socialism that's par for the course i
mean that's
that's a a feature not a bug completely
expected
part of the package still worth mocking
though and of course
you know only rich people are going to
buy this sweater
saying tax the rich every person who
buys this sweater will be rich
comparatively rich i mean i'm not saying
that you have to be rich you have to be
a millionaire
to a 458 sweater but if you're buying
sweaters
with snazzy slogans for 58 bucks that
probably means you've achieved a level
of wealth and luxury
far above the vast majority of the globe
at a minimum in fact if you're buying
sweaters for 30 bucks
you you're probably in that category as
most people in america are
one other aoc related thing here i
enjoyed this tweet from her
she says republicans like to make fun of
the fact that i used to be a waitress
but we all know if they ever had to do a
double they'd be the ones found crying
in the walk-in fridge halfway through
their first shift
because someone yelled at them for
bringing seltzer when they really wanted
sparkling water
now there's a lot to unpack here um
starting with
this idea she has that working a double
is
some sort of some sort of a really
impressive thing that very few people
have done
what you think you think republicans
have never worked double shifts
um i've worked double shifts a lot of us
have it's it's
it's not terribly impressive but also
this is such a specific scenario she's
giving
like it really sounds like this is a
person with a lot of experience
crying and walking fridges i've i've
worked doubles i've worked in the food
industry
um i've i've never cried in a walk-in
fridge
i've never been tempted to cry in a
walk-in fridge
i've never seen anybody crying in a
walk-in fridge i mean that would be
awkward if you just run in to grab the
frozen cheese or whatever and there's
someone
breaking down in tears in the middle of
the freezer what do you do about that
so this this this sounds like a woman
and no surprise here but it
sounds like a woman who did a lot of
crying in a lot of walking fridges my
other question is why the walk-in fridge
of all
of all the places to cry i guess i you
know i understand that it's a
isolated place but it seems a little it
doesn't seem like the most comfortable
place for a crying fit
i mean why not go to the bathroom for
that if it were me
now i've already made clear men of
course don't cry in general especially
not at work
but if i had to choose a spot for it i
would think probably the bathroom stall
is the best place
it's not as cold you know it's more more
privacy
but that's uh that's alexandria cortez
yeah i
i could definitely see that from her she
gets yelled at for
first of all i could see her getting the
order wrong and bringing the wrong kind
of water
and then crying because someone said and
it doesn't have to be that she's getting
chewed out about it just someone says oh
hey uh
you brought me uh you brought me seltzer
i wanted sparkling water then she just
breaks down in tears and runs out of the
room
um in any case by the way ben shapiro is
gonna be
has more maybe not on the crying in the
walk-in fridge thing maybe he'll talk
about that too because it's a great
topic but um
the tax the rich sweater ben's been on
top of this on twitter and he's gonna
have more on that
uh great perspective on that so tune in
to his show for that we've we've got one
other one other headline here
um and in fact maybe no setup is needed
i'll just show you this video if you
haven't seen it this is share
the singer share uh singing to
an elephant listen smiling
no matter how your heart is grieving
if you people believe
the dream that you wish
will come true
i yeah i don't know why that's happening
uh the elephant's name is kavan if
you're wondering who the victim is here
share flute to a zoo in pakistan
to sing to the elephant you know
um i don't know what the elephant did to
deserve that treatment
uh you know i'm not a big animal rights
guy but this
level of animal cruelty is shocking to
me personally upsetting
um is this sort of some sort of
punishment regime from the zoo
like you step out of line they call
share up to come sing
that's really really rough it's not much
different from the way that i punish my
own kids in fact
except that i make if they're out of
line talk back or something i make them
listen to beyonce
a cappella which is pretty harrowing but
and then reading from from more from the
pink news article it says
and just trying to figure out what's
going on here and why this is happening
um i mean this might just this is share
with them this is just how she spends
her weekend i guess she just goes around
singing
to elephants but it says after
serenading kevan cher flew with the
elephant to cambodia
where he was greeted by buddhist monks
he had to be tested for covet 19 before
his flight
they needed a pretty big swab for that
for that test i guess
so she sang to him and then brought him
on a plane to meet with buddhist monks
you know what i maybe it's best to not
try to understand this and to just let
it go
right there and that's it now is
definitely the time if you're not a
daily wire member now is the time to do
it because we've got so much stuff
coming up
right around the corner uh you know
certainly into the new year but
even before the new year michael knowles
just uh just rolled out his
five day a week show with more content
for members to enjoy
we're also adding the entire prageru
catalog to thedailywire.com
uh that's all going to be there by the
end of the year but we've already got
some stuff there candace owens is
joining the daily wire and she'll be
here in nashville she'll be launching a
new show
with a live audience we're excited about
that we're building an uh
investigative journalism team we're
doing feature films we're doing a lot of
stuff
so if you want to go outside the
narrative you got to come over to
dailywire.com
subscribe we're loud we're opinionated
we're having a good time at least some
of us are over
dailywire.com um and also
uh this is not so much of a good time
but the christmas ornaments we've been
talking about if you want to hang us
in effigy on your tree you can text
christmas to 83400
to get your tree decorated and i think
even better than that
we told you about the the the tax the
rich sweatshirt well we've got our own
two can play at that game hey you'll see
we've got our own sweatshirts um so you
can check out our new
insert woke slogan shirt and so you know
you can that's that's a good thing we're
not going to tell you what woke slogan
just whatever woke slogan you want um
that's the shirt our shirt by the way is
cheaper than aoc's
socialism sweatshirt and you could check
it out by texting woke
to 83400 go check out that sweatshirt
now now we'll get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
so today we're going to preemptively
cancel vaccine mandates
um this week the department of defense
released an image
of the trustee new covid 19 vaccination
record card
that you'll you might have in your
wallet cnn explains quote vaccination
cards will be used as the simplest way
to keep track of covert 19
shots said dr kelly moore associate
director of the immunization action
coalition
everybody will be issued a written card
that they can put in their wallet
that will tell them what what they had
and when their next
dose is due moore said quote let's do
the simple easy thing first
everyone's going to get that vaccination
clinics will also be reporting to their
state immunization registries
what vaccine was given so that for
example an entity could run a query
if it didn't know where a patient got a
first dose
moore said many places are planning to
ask patients to voluntarily
voluntarily provide a cell phone number
so they can get a text message telling
them
when and where their next dose is
scheduled to be administered
okay now to be clear they're not saying
at the moment
that you'll have to carry this card
around with you at all times
or that you'll be required to present it
in order to access goods and services
but there's a strong push in that
direction right now with some major
industries
publicly toying with the idea this is a
live debate
in the airline industry for example and
australia's qantas airways has already
announced
that they will eventually only allow
those who can prove they've gotten the
vaccine on their flights
the same discussion is being had among
schools
the miami-dade county superintendent has
already said that vaccines
could be mandatory for students next
year and elsewhere you can find plenty
of headlines like on cnbc it says
can your employer require you to get a
covered vaccine here's what experts say
by the way they all appear to be saying
yes
and then on yahoo should the coronavirus
vaccine be mandatory
now all this makes it clear that vaccine
mandates
are not a conspiracy theory this there's
a very good chance we're heading in that
direction
and there are many powerful forces
trying to push us there
as for the gov the government forcing us
to get the vaccine that has also been
discussed
but mostly in an intentionally indirect
and confusing kind of way
for example here's joe biden giving his
thoughts on
whether the government can and should
mandate vaccinations
tell me if you can make sense of this
you should be thinking about making a
man how could you enforce that
well you couldn't that's the problem
just like you can't afford you can't
enforce measles
you can't come to school unless you have
a measles shot you know you can't but
you can't say
everyone has to do this but you would
just like you can't mandate a mask
but you can say you can go to every
governor and get them all in a room
all 50 of them as president and say ask
people to wear the mask
everybody knows and if they don't they
don't no not fine then i go to every
governor i go to every mayor i go to
every council and i go to every local
official
say mandate the mask man say this is
what you have to do when you're out
i don't know if you got that according
to joe biden the government
can't mandate it but they can tell
everyone they have to do it
isn't that a mandate how do you define
mandate if that
isn't a mandate but the ambiguity is the
point
they aren't going to be forthcoming
about their real plans and intentions
and they haven't been this entire time
and again that's not a conspiracy theory
that's an observation
so um look a few things here first of
all as for my own position
on the covet vaccine and any other
vaccine it's very simple
you know i've never been dogmatic when
it comes to vaccines
i believe that if you want the vaccine
you should get it if you don't want it
you shouldn't get it
that's it um it is perfectly sensible to
make your
make your own decisions make them based
on you know your own risk level
you may determine that you're at a very
low risk for covet
not not everybody has the same risk
there are some people and some
demographics that have a very low risk
and so you may look at yourself and say
you know i don't want to get the vaccine
i don't need it
you may decide that you're high risk and
so that you so you do want to get
both of those choices are valid or you
may decide that you're uncomfortable
with getting a new vaccine that's been
made so quickly
now you'll be treated like a wacky
conspiracy monger if you if you take
that position now
but you'll remember that that was the
position taken by andrew cuomo and many
democrats
very recently cuomo said he wouldn't
necessarily trust a vaccine rushed out
quote unquote by the trump
administration
many democrats were very reluctant to
say that they would get the shot if
trump was the guy
in charge now they've all changed their
tune because they're anticipating a
biden presidency
but they said what they said and they
cannot credibly claim now that it's
unreasonable to be wary about the very
vaccine
that they were publicly wary about not
but a few weeks ago
but again to my way of thinking this is
entirely up to the individual
you know it's interesting that the
people who normally scream about bodily
autonomy
seem to abandon that ship whenever the
topic of vaccines comes up
now personally i think that bodily
autonomy is a basically nonsensical term
but if it could if it could make sense
in relation to any subject it would be
this
if we have bodily autonomy then the
government or anyone else
trying to force you to inject a
substance into your body
must violate it and bili autonomy aside
i am simply in principle opposed to the
idea that any adult in america
should be required to inject or ingest
anything
that they don't want to inject or ingest
doesn't matter what the thing is
i oppose it on principle and i don't
think that's some kind of radical
libertarian position
one other thing to consider if we do end
up needing vaccination cards as a
requirement for entry into government
buildings
stores schools planes
invariably the people who support these
policies and
who help to put them in place will be
the same people almost without exception
who would tell you that it's a horrific
infringement on personal liberty to
require ids to vote
requiring an id to vote these people say
is
onerous unfair even racist somehow
even though the point of the id the idea
is just to make sure that you are who
you say you are that's it
it's not to ensure that you've done
something or you've jumped a certain
hurdle
much less injected or ingested anything
into your body
it's just to verify that you are who you
say you are
and yet that is too much that is a great
burden
but vaccine cards we will be told were
already being told are totally different
though of course the people saying that
won't be able to explain how they're
totally different because they can never
explain
anything they say we are expected to
simply shut up
and comply as always and that is why the
kobe vaccine mandate
and those who push it are preemptively
canceled i'm going to get in early to
cancel it ahead of time
it's the only way to be safe and that'll
do it for us today
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening have a great day godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio was mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle
well tune in to the ben shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more see you there